- Okay, Bill Goldberg here
for another installment
of "Tu's Tutorial,"
with Tu Lam.
This rope has taken down
a number of competitors.
The floor is yours.
- Well, first, you need
a fast, slashing blade.
If I hit the blade
at a 3 position,
look at the contour
of that blade.
It's just going to slash,
but it's pushing the object
out of my blade path.
If I'm able to generate power
coming in from the 1:00
down to the 7,
that's going to give me
my angle of attack.
The reason why I want to go
to a steep angle
is because there's no weight
at the end of this rope.
If I come in at a steep angle,
basically, it pulls the rope.
It tightens the rope as I'm
cutting through it at an angle.
It won't push the rope
out of my blade's path,
and I want to generate as much
power and speed as I can
at a very steep angle
going down.
This is really hard,
because, Bill,
it requires a lot of accuracy.
It requires angles of attack.
And in the end,
it's about speed and violence.
Blade management
has a lot to do with it.
Let's just say if I
hit this at the tip.
You see how I just
ran out of blade.
I want to hit this thing here,
and then, pull down
in a slashing motion.
- You want to maximize as much
of that blade as possible.
- It's not an impact,
it's a slash.
Distance will generate
where I'm going to impact it
on my blade.
If I'm too far away,
I'm going to hit it at the tip.
I want to measure the distance
comparing to the geometry
of my blade.
If I have a longsword,
I'm going to be back
a little bit more.
I have a short katana,
I'm going to be closer.
- And about where on the rope?
Is it adjusted to your height,
or is it adjusted to where
the rope is actually centered?
- You want to adjust it
to your height,
because I don't want
to swing it high.
- Understood.
- I want to swing it
where I personally am going
to generate the most power.
For me, it's around right here.
- Show us how it's done.
Hi-ya!
Our tutorial is over.